ça va ça va très bien japonais militaire
du soir qu'ils ont été drôlement bien
c'est mignon c'est jean mimi pas son nom
mais les doigts un petit peu un petit
peu artiste gens c'est beau cette
collection j'aime bien tu sais les
choses avec environ des choses qu'on a
vues bien c'est donc toi en fait quand
tu rencontres un mec tu parles pas de ta
collection d'estampés japonaises tu dis
viens voir mon intrigue car à mon art
africain en général ça plaît bien
est-ce que ça doit plaire aux africains
il n'y a pas seulement aux africaine
devrait s'appeler aux autres ils pensent
que j'ai fait des petits voyages en
afrique tu vois puis j'aime bien avec
les poutres bus et les les invités quels
qu'ils soient même ce très beau dit dans
les toits c'est bien les toilettes sont
au fond voilà où il faut y aller c'est
juste la leur la porte est en face la
salle de bains toilettes
[Musique]
li 28e souviens qu'on avait fait des
photos ensemble ya un pas combien de
temps il ya des photos pour lui pour blé
bol non de la bande revient et puis
j'étais la dernière la 12e ouais bah oui
dominique on est en disette en ton nom
de garçons dominé en disait maman du
garçon mais bon on le dit plus ouais
c'est vrai c'était déjà un peu à l'ombre
fille dominique c'est un petit peu à
nomix battu c'était le choix quand tu
changes de d'identité c'est un dominique
ou claude bayala pas 36 rue dominique
allons-y mais tous mes amis m'appellent
florence et un regard de florence pour
l'administration c'est dominique non
mais les deux je réponds aux deux bidons
il y avait entre temps là en 15 ans
transsexuels c'est quand même beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins transgressif qu'à
l'époque parce que maintenant avec dumas
toutes les semaines on atterrit oui mais
je sais tu sais qu'il s'est passé m'a
ouvert deux ans à deux cantons et
transsexuels de voir si facile que ça à
la télé ouais non j'ai vite un petit peu
de regarder parce que il y en a beaucoup
ensuite je les trouve très malheureuse
et je me reconnais pas vraiment dans le
déjà malema a non non non non c'est pas
raison aux circuits et puis le bas les
masques qui se verront tgp à 10 heures
douloureuses a raconté
et on avait fait un petit film pour la
télé qui avait été la voir mireille
dumas qu'était du temps d'ailleurs de ce
qu'on avait fait ce qu'on avait fait oui
de playboy et c'est pas du tout marché
parce que il avait vu une transsexuelle
qui était heureuse heureuse de la très
bien pas de problème ça je passe des
amis des amants et ça ça marche pas du
tout parce qu'il voulait que je sois
angoissé que ça soit pénible que ma mère
mais je n'ai pas leur j'entends très
bien que ma maman méfiance et même bien
comme ça et donc tu vois la télévision
ou de mireille dumas faut expier tu vois
un petit peu la rédemption et a le droit
d'être ce que tu veux d'être marginal
mais t'as pas le droit d'être heureux
il faut le payer pour moi je le paye pas
je suis tout de suite j'ai un nom déjà
l'appartement qui me plaît je suis
heureuse d'être transsexuels je suis pas
une femme
hélas mais bon ça on ne pourra jamais
rien tu fais pas loin non je suis pas le
mois non je pense que non tout
qu'intérieurement tout à fait mais bon
il ya eu un petit faut faire avec mais
c'est plutôt agréable
puis bon il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
les femmes c'est ce que je te dise oui
on est combien on est des milliards de
femmes dont je n'ai pas envie d'en faire
une de plus puis je crois qu'on a le
droit mais sexuellement comment ça va
bien ça va très bien très bien oui moi
je sais que j'adore ça je dirais l'amour
à l'époque j'avais beaucoup dame en noir
avec oui ben j'ai eu une époque un petit
peu blacks comme ça parce que je
trouvais déjà les blacks étaient moins à
la mode du cic de vagues après c'est un
petit peu énervé et puis c'était pas des
blacks c'était des noirs et c'est bien
pourquoi tu sais pas ce que les blacks
maintenance et les rappeurs de la main
toutes les filles de bourges même type
lac dans leur poche comme ça moi c'était
des africains ces dernières sont gentils
mais bon j'ai gardé de bons rapports il
me téléphone ils sont mariés quand ils
ont des enfants aiment écrire je trouve
ça très gentille j'ai vécu pendant
combien cinq ans que maintenant c'est
plutôt le beurre dont à j'aime bien les
petits bugs mais j'aime bien le petit
blond c'est ce qui est agréable en fin
de compte c'est le mélange we7 pas
choisir cette les problèmes et le nombre
le nombre c'est important aussi
ouais tu veux dire à nombre cheval avec
les longues de frais personnels non le
nombre de mecs pas trois quatre cinq
raids à trois quatre cinq mecs oui c'est
plus c'est plutôt agréable
il aime bien ça d'ailleurs ça fait un
peu c'est sam ou détestable mais c'est
festif nîmois savez le genre on s'éclate
c'est un délire
et puis c'est un petit peu curieux de
voir les autres mecs aussi comment ils
font quand même là où il habite du
copain c'est toujours rigolo
et puis de voir je crois devoir faire
l'amour aussi sa sélection
c'est là que ça se passe là bas c'est là
que ça se passe tu vas si intimement
avec la glagla sont les 10 et puis c'est
quand même une chose
sont un petit peu bizarre parce que les
garçons si on croit que c'est moi qu'on
regarde dans la glace mais un lieu qui
n'est guère mieux qu'ils adorent s'y
regarde et je trouve très beau jeu ça il
ya un petit hors les années qui m'avait
dit [ __ ] qu'est-ce que je suis beau
quand je baise et c'est vrai qu'il était
beau quand il venait me l'avez jamais vu
j'aime bien quand ils font ce genre de
petits réflexion alors ben j'étais dans
15 ans adam se met dans le bon sens tu
vois ça c'est le sens ce clasico rayé la
peinture
d'accord on va dire ça pour s'asseoir
aussi c'est très important alors est ce
que tu te fais comprendre ce qui se
passe est bien le premier il faut
prendre un petit peu celui qu'on aime
bien c'est à dire celui qu'on a envie de
faire plaisir tu vois on la longe ça
passe quand les gars vous aime bien
qu'on s'occupe d'eux dont on l'allongé
puis ce que tu fais c'est que d'abord
fatigue mais bien dessus à fond comme ça
vous pouvez retirer ça parce que c'est
un petit peu gênant puisque ça fait pas
le diabolique en général tu sais j'aime
pas être tout à fait nu et tout à fait
voilà j'aime bien qu'ils aient un petit
quelque chose
enfin t'as rien composé d'un contrôle de
police
ah non j'aime bien les noeuds qui soit
diabolique ou pas peux-tu c'est en fin
de compte j'aime bien ce qu'il ya autour
aussi les noeuds c'est via mail maquis
autour c'est pas mal non plus parce que
pas seulement des godemichés non j'aime
pas le genre godemiché a pas tous un
petit peu gênante il ya des bonnes
femmes c'est de la chair à saucisse et
les mecs c'est des godemichés appâter
bon je trouve que c'est quand même pas
vrai parce que les mecs je ne ferai pas
tout ça si je les aimais pas tu
comprends parce que le sexe comme ça bon
ben c'est un petit peu peep show c'est
un peu le truc mais fait un petit peu de
temps presse
il aime ça aussi quand on est alors bon
on va recommencer l'opération mais tu
vois là tu commences d'abord tu le mets
bien à fond tu t'assieds dessus comme ça
latulippe
3 ch et puis parce qu'il aime bien quand
même ça tire un petit peu les nénés chat
il adore ça et là tu es déjà prises
alors évidemment qu'est-ce qui fait le
clou ch'ti qui se dit bon il reste à il
reste un petit un petit coin à prendre
donc il prend et celui qui est en
dessous merveille il bouge pas tu
comprends mais il est bien il sent
simplement à travers la petite membrane
du voile l'habite du copain qui frotte
donc ça lui donne du plaisir sans qu'ils
aient besoin de remuer dans toi tu te
laisses un petit peu hâlé il bassin très
saoul faut pas trop remuer parce que tu
sais à ce moment là sa part ou devant tu
déconnes du déclin donc non il faut
quand même rester un petit peu bien très
souple et bien assise puis tu as les
trois loustics arrive qu'ils aient
[ __ ] qu'est-ce qu'ils s'envoient en
l'air et où ils ont envie de participer
alors depuis c'est un petit peu
tristounet aussi pourquoi il pourquoi
pas moi alors venez alors on se dit
tiens mais toi de le ce côté-là lauriane
wahl appelé bruno tourisme et de ce côté
là il ya tiric et de ce côté là et
puisqu'il faut surtout pas faire alors
là on est toujours en bonne position ça
marche un moule à rien n'est sorti faut
surtout pas les prendre comme ça tu leur
dis de se mettre à genoux comme ça tu
les prends comme ça pour que le
mouvement
tu vas que le mec à l'arrière te donne
aille dans le bon sens
et puis en plus que les mecs déteste
quand même c'est de sentir les copains
qui gicle sur eux ça ne nous aiment pas
ils aiment bien vers leur plaisir et
c'est bien de voir leur donner du
plaisir
mm pas sentir tu vois ce que je veux
dire donc ça permet bon bah oui les
petits caoutchouc ça oui ça on les a mis
le caoutchouc
et puis il y en a qui restent à la porte
comme ça elle se dit bon mais c'est très
joli tout ça mais qu'est ce que je fais
alors lui ça soit ici tu comprends ça
soit juste sur le tir bas si bien que au
plus souvent il se met aussi tu cèdes
les deux genoux de chaque côté et ça
permet à celui qui est en dessous de
mater un petit peu ce qui se passe parce
que le plaisir c'est aussi de voir alors
tu vois tu fais bien ce mouvement-là
l'hô te pousse là tu l'as dans la bouche
et puis bah ça dure que l'on dit rond
comme ça
ah ça dure un petit peu longtemps parce
que ils sont un petit peu un petit peu
gêné comme apparaît pas gêner exciter un
petit peu troublé un petit peu ému parce
qu'il pratique salon sur cette position
bon après ça comment toi oh non
j'appelle reste à une position le
porte-avions et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux